das richtige dass alle sich
zusammenreißen dass man sich um die
Dinge kümmert die die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger in diesem Land bewegen die helfen
das Land voranzubringen und
ich hatte eigentlich ich hatte
eigentlich gehofft dass über den Sommer
alle noch mal reflektiert haben was mit
dem heizungsgesetz auch vor der
Sommerpause passiert ist da haben wir
selbst
dazu beigetragen dass Verunsicherung in
der Bevölkerung gestiegen ist das
Unklarheit da war das Unzufriedenheit
doch gewachsen ist und ich meine jeder
der am Kabinett zwischen sitzt das ist
ja ein Privileg auch diesen tollen Land
dienen zu dürfen indem man Ministerin
oder Minister ist und ich erwarte von
jedem dass man auch dann den Pflichten
nachgeht und dass man dazu beiträgt und
ich gehe schon davon aus dass er das
alle auch gehört haben und dass wir
jetzt sehr schnell zu einer Einigung
kommt sowohl was die Frage der
wirtschaftlich helfen angeht da warten
die Unternehmerinnen drauf da warten die
Gewerkschaften und die Beschäftigten
drauf als auch bei der Frage der
Kindergrundsicherung das ist ja kein
entweder oder sondern es geht um beides
und ich erwarte dass das jetzt sehr
schnell in der Regierung umgesetzt wird
[Musik]